okay for the next three weeks if you see
me eating carbs I need you just slap me
across the face okay Sabrina carpenter
we absolutely loved you in tall girl but
how did you manage to play such a
clueless character it was hilarious how
your character Harper had so many
historical facts wrong hand you acted so
sure of yourself even though your sister
kept correcting you we know you're way
smarter in real life it just proves how
great of an actress you are sometimes
our favorite fictional characters aren't
all that smart but usually the actors
who play them are beyond intelligence
keep watching to see which ten actresses
are a lot smarter than the characters
they play does Cameron okay we aren't
saying that mal is dumb she's definitely
not the mal it's kind of a mess
sometimes she makes bad decisions like
lying to her friends or Brighton away
from auradon and she's asked to be
confident even though she pretends to be
the deaf Cameron is really smart in real
life she often posts very insightful and
philosophical things on her social media
she is well-spoken and knows exactly who
she is she's way more emotionally
intelligent than mouth and posts
vulnerable things like how much she
misses her dad Mackenzie Ziegler Kenzie
Ziegler plays cassie on brats total
eclipse and cassie is such a daydreamer
she always has her head in the clouds
she's not always super aware of what is
going on around her but Kenzie is not
that way at all I mean I always just try
to find the positive side of things and
I love to be happy and make my friends
and she's only 15 but she is super
grounded
she has already written a book called
Kenzie's rules for life and she talks
about all the ways she stays happy and
positive she's very mature cassie is
nothing like that Chloe grace Moretz
Chloe grace Moretz voice Wednesday
Addams in the newly animated Addams
Family movie Wednesday is a witty girl
but she is also completely clueless
about the real world you're weakening
the gene pool Chloe's totally different
she is a smart businesswoman and a
fabulous actress she was on the campaign
trail in the 2016 presidential election
she's very self-aware and has talked
about how important communication and
accountability is we'd never expect
that from Wednesday lies Akashi you
probably know lies Akashi from her show
lyza on demand in that show her
character wants to be an elite Tasker
she's goofy and uses her dizziness as
humor I'm going as alexandra Ocasio
cortez for halloween but liza is nothing
like that
she's well-spoken and she is extremely
talented she's also a director and she
recently joined the Directors Guild of
America that's quite an accomplishment
she's got a lot more ambition than her
character does Lilia Buckingham Lilia
Buckingham plays autumn on the brat show
dirt now autumn is not a dumb character
at all alright dad no I'm at the stupid
track every day and I don't even like
motocross that bad yourself
go take some photos but she's it for the
average character when you compare it to
Lilia Malia is talented at whatever she
does she's a hard worker and she has
even written a book Lilia co-authored a
novel about social media influencers
with Sara Shepard it comes out in early
2020 you have to be really smart to
write a book the LEAs brightness comes
through in every single interview ariana
grande ariana grande got her start on
Nickelodeon's victorious
she played Kat Kat was a ditzy and
dim-witted character she was totally
clueless and not smart at all but Ariana
is a different story
not only is she a super talented singer
she is a feminist activist she is wise
beyond her years ariana is all about
equality and she speaks out about it a
lot she is vocal about not fitting into
a box and she believes that no woman
should have to be a certain way it's
clear that ariana is a lot smarter than
Kat Sabrina carpenter we absolutely
loved Sabrina carpenter and tall girl
she was a great big sister to Jody
God but her character wasn't that smart
she was completely clueless about the
thing she was studying in college the
jokes about General Custer being a hero
and dodi correcting her were hilarious
but Sabrina is the opposite she is very
intelligent she is incredibly passionate
about music and acting she puts her all
into it and she makes smart business
decisions
Amandla Stenberg a manless Tandberg
played star in the movie the hate you
give which dealt with serious racial
issues star was a smart character but
Amanda's intelligence is next-level
she's been outspoken about racial
discrimination ever since the Hunger
Games in which she played Rou she came
out of the closet as a teenager and she
is very vocal about her identity she is
also a body positivity champion she is
the definition of woke a man loved
refuses to hide just to protect her
career she's such a role model Ava
Michelle
Ava Michelle's character and tall girl
was Jodie Jodie is book smarts but she
is clueless about the world she really
thinks she's a lovable just because
she's tall it's the thing that's haunted
me my entire life even though she has
two friends who adore her
but ava is way more emotionally
intelligent she has overcome a lot of
bullying and really loves herself she is
a big advocate for self love and
confidence which is super inspiring
Rowan Blanchard who didn't love Riley
Matthews in Girl Meets World Riley
wasn't a dumb character by any means but
Rowan Blanchard is extra billions she is
extremely informed about all sorts of
political and social issues and she uses
her fame for activism she speaks out
about everything from feminism to gun
violence she even spoke with the United
Nations at a conference for women's
rights Rowan is a force to be reckoned
with and she has no intention of slowing
down
which of these actors is your favorite
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching subscribe to the things and
give this video a big thumbs up see you
next time
you